welcome to this video honey bar to
Hannibal from Austria and rails dear
Maya okay well don't know this guy let's
see probably Queens gambit iam yeah
let's stay within the Queens gambit yeah
again the semi sloth I don't really have
a great line at least nothing that I
feel very out to date huh let's see
there is the stuff with B 3 which I
normally don't like but there is I think
there is a five at some point gem okay
it's not going for that okay an owie
form now I think white normally place
for this kind of full centralization and
delaying those central moves
aha so he's doing something hmm okay but
I'm not in in in bad shape here I think
wyd some setup is quite harmonious um
should I go g3 Bishop g2 warm yeah I
guess so get the bishop on the long
diagonal move like 94 I can answer with
detect see ok so he probably while
taking on d 494 this immediately night
f5 so that's not happening and I'm
threatening now to take on c5 and play
Knight h4 ok may I can also take which
is not so bad yeah but it's not that's
not ideal ok so if I take it I can take
with the rook no real alternative Queen
d3 was my idea I need to get out of the
pin and now maybe if possible nighty to
to deform or still night deform I'm also
threatening to take on e4 simply because
his he's got so much pieces so many
pieces on the D file like 94 d 4 26
which wins material ok
if I take on any form de Queen d6 ef3
queen e 7 now that's that's quite ok for
me so it probably has to take with the
night nope he thinks he does not have to
take with the night I thought that this
should be good for wide let's see i can
take here first or i can just play
Bishop everyone yeah maybe a move like
94 is some problem or just rupee 6am i
can just play rugby 6am it takes f F
takes a g2 i take p 7 so that's quite ok
Jeff Bishop has to move somewhere then I
will just play Bishop everyone I guess
the only thing that forfeits due to this
connection okay is it that bad already
it is pretty bad but maybe it was really
disconnect you never know um yeah yes to
move the bishop I guess somewhere not
sure where I am here yeah and this is
just I'm upon up and there's really no
great play for black if he does
something like that I can just take
everything this is some two pawns and
the structure I don't think is counter
player so it's dangerous hm you can take
f2 but it's not leading to much well
there's this thus this is not really
dangerous I mean if it does something
like that check check check winning
straight away yeah I don't think the
opening of the center was very much to
blakes advantage right here this is
certainly okay went here I went here now
I played 90 fire okay takes takes takes
what is the computer giving here 95 with
the quality yeah okay 95 TX Bishop takes
yeah this is ok I black ass very active
him I can do something like that which
is probably about equal yeah but this I
don't know TX yeah he has to take with
the night and why it is slightly but I
am this is what I expected but
this is quite quite obviously not
working I was expecting this which is
not as bad as the game but ok white is
better now with the two bishops and
those spawns a week also threatening a
Rukia now something like this is some
quite quite quite logical and why this
is a bit better with the bishops but
it's nothing nothing so terrible the
compass on stock fish is on one point
something 1.1 but well why does better
of it I'm not winning straight away or
anything ok thanks for watching